[Music]
hannah's with us in raleigh north
carolina hi hannah welcome to the ramsay
show
hi there how are you better than i
deserve how can george and i help
okay um so i am let's see
basically i've been um not in debt but
also not
broke um
i've been
see i'm trying to get my background here
so backstory i just came into
300 000 of liquid assets because my
father passed away i'm sorry
um
it's it's fine it's kind of a redemption
story sort of interesting but
he
um we hadn't found him for 17 years so
through this he resurfaced and um
we were all joking wouldn't it be funny
if he died a millionaire turned out he
did
basically
and he left
this to us four kids we split it four
ways so um
basically i have gone to from just kind
of being the average
uh
average girl that's
not really planning for the future to
now i have this chunk
to
have this opportunity to do something
smart so
how old are you um
i'm i'm i'm kind of old
i'm thirsty
i can't believe you how do you get
around
36. i don't know
i got socks than that
oh my god good new socks thank you
actually
yeah um but yeah so i mean i went to
college late and then i've just been
working what do you mean
how much do you make
so currently
uh
i haven't even done the math on that 20
bucks an hour it's not something to
frown at i don't think
um
what does that come to 40 000 a year
maybe 45 44 or something like that yeah
so and that's um
no i currently i have i'm down to two
thousand dollars of debt i've never had
much debt i've stayed out of it
um i did me i did get a college degree
because my grandma offered to buy me one
so i don't have any student loans um i
wouldn't have gone to school so what's
your question for us today
so my question is mainly well here's the
other side of the story my husband and i
both run our own businesses and we've
gotten to the point where we both agreed
that having our own property to do it is
going to be ultimately
um the smartest way to do it so uh
at your job what kind of a business do
you have oh currently i have well i have
my own personal business that i'm
starting and it's not it's not like
underway because i don't have a place to
do it so i've got it i've got a lot of
clear business
um it's it's a whole it's a pony
operation basically we've got i've got
this is
people think i'm crazy i've got three
ponies that i've managed to keep through
leaving my parents house going through
college everything i've supported them
the whole way
um and they do like pony rides and they
do
ultimately i want to be doing equine
therapy so i've been educating myself
for a while what does your husband do
he's a pro recording engineer he's got a
full pro studio
um that he bought for himself
and he's already got you know album
one more time then i'm gonna circle back
what's your question
my question is
um
what the husband thinks is we should
just go ahead and spend this on a
property or a house because we've got it
and then we
um
basically he's talking about being
passport get a place and then have no
mortgage and wouldn't that be awesome
and my thing is yes but i have you know
a lot of uh 83 000 is like iras and the
rest of stocks and my thought is well if
you put it into one hard asset then none
of it's working for you
and
advisors are telling me oh this is a
great time to get a mortgage because
it's at like three percent interest at
the most to get a mortgage
um so my question is do i go into a
mortgage or do i go ahead and just spend
this chunk on a house and continue being
who i am which is the girl who just got
you okay so
i i wouldn't do this unless you've got a
paid for house but it sounds like you
don't need this property right now
so i don't know you said you had some
single stocks going on as well
i would get a new financial advisor if
they're telling you to go into debt and
they're telling you to invest in single
stocks the reason they want you to go
into debt is they don't want you to use
this money they would rather make a
commission on this money when they
invest it for you
they have a little bit of a conflict of
interest in their advice to say the
least
so there's a lot going on here all right
so let me just i'm just going to be real
plain with you kiddo
pony lady meets
recording engineer
two
ideas both of which have a high
probability of losing your butt
losing money running these as full-time
businesses and so do not invest in the
property to do either one of these
business ideas rent the property to do
these business ideas on a commercial
basis
invest in and buy a home and pay cash
with it with this money
that way you can't get to the money and
screw it up
and then go live your life on your
income go create some income to build
your businesses with and to grow your
pony business and for him to grow his
recording business but all on a rental
basis
do not buy commercial recording studios
never i'm in nashville
you know you get the next country music
star's attention in nashville uh waiter
and so they're on every corner and
there's a there's a dadgum recording
studio in every trailer in a 50-mile
radius around here it's ridiculous don't
put money in that
period and don't put and don't and your
business your pony business is a hobby
it's not a business it's never been a
business it's been a hobby since college
so it's okay to try to grow these things
but do them on rental properties and own
your house paid for cash to protect you
from you
that's what i'm hearing that's a little
blunt but that's what i heard